Jenny wrote in hey David can you address
the controversy about whether chili is a
soup I have very strong feeling feelings
on this of course
chili is not a soup chili is a stew and
when you say here's here's the the most
direct way to get me to this if you say
to someone do you want some soup and
then they say oh what kind of soup do
you have
oh the type of soup I have is chili you
don't hear that conversation because
chili is not under the category of soup
it is a stew and I that it's broth
related right when I was reached where
if there's broth then it's a soup well
number one depending on how you make
your chili it doesn't really have broth
sometimes it does sometimes it doesn't
but if the idea that pieces of food in
liquid is a soup that means cereal is a
soup because after all you're putting
grains inside of liquid and nobody would
say that cereal is a soup so merely the
idea of solid food in liquid being a
soup is wrong and cereal proves the case
I do agree with you on this one and I
think it has to do with the fact that
you put already cooked meats inside of
it so that makes it a stew if you were
to cook it all together then you would
create this like chicken broth yeah
beef broth and that would make excuse me
vegan intervention if I may I don't know
if you've ever made a meat based chili
but the meats not precooked
what are you talking about not precooked
no I mean you you might put it in early
with the onions and the tomato paste but
the meat is not precooked I don't know
what kind of chilli Pat's ever seen you
know what
let's go because this is curing scandal
x 10 precooked meat makes chili not as
soon I say something else I would revise
and extend your state I think well no
just forget about it I think I think
soups are predominantly liquid okay
you're sticking with that I'm sticking
with it I actually don't think that
that's the strongest argument but that
is it's an one that often comes up but I
believe that chili is a meal
in and of itself it is not a soup and
that's it that I just don't see much of
an argument of it but if anybody has
ever heard of these precooked meat
chiles that Pat is referencing by all
means send in an email because I don't
cook the meat and then add it in later
no you don't like dry it up or something
you don't know what you do with me you
know I've I've never seen that done with
chili you all it all gets cooked in the
same pot you want to brown the meat
along with the onions and garlic in the
bottom of the pot I think that there
it's true that there's probably a cheap
way to do it which is you buy already
cooked something I don't even know what
it would be but I just get ground turkey
and a couple turkey sausages and then
you put them in and then they cook while
the chiles cooking okay a chili not a
soup no doubt about it send me your
thoughts great bonus show today we're
out of time sign up at david pakman.com
slash membership patreon.com slash david
pakman show